there was reading
if lucifer can just choose to take a
vacation from hell is it truly an
eternal condemnation i'm very conflicted
about sinning this show largely because
i feel like an abundance of sins is
exactly what the devil would want so in
the interests of balance if all the
lucifer fans out there could be extra
outraged in the comments you know to
compensate it would be greatly
appreciated license and registration
coming right up lucifer likes to be
flashy and feels like he's above the law
because i guess technically he is and i
get all that but wouldn't it be easier
in this scenario to just produce the
license and registration and get on with
this night we're going to see 372
incidents of lucifer being a pompous ass
before this episode is over so a little
less flash here would have been fine and
no need to check the math because they
don't call me the abacus of youtube
narrators for nothing also bribing an
officer of the law you've written a
little sometimes don't you sometimes
lucifer is a very attractive man with a
sexy accent and piercing eyes but i very
much doubt that that would
be enough
yes lucifer i have dark desires
sometimes i think about not returning my
shopping cart once i'm done with it damn
it lucifer you handsome bastard once in
for revealing my deepest darkest desire
in the world people like to tell me
things ask me something about his face
lucifer has no qualms about telling
others he's immortal and all the other
things he's capable of doing for the
rest of the episode he goes by his real
[ __ ] name even so why is he being so
coy with this random cop thank you
patrick you can go i have it on good
authority that if she can still hold a
conversation while he's doing that he's
probably not doing it right but i didn't
leave hell to be a bartender oh come on
now that's not fair you're far more than
just a bartender you're an expositional
bartender much better you're the lord of
hell for crying out loud does hell even
need a lord or somebody in charge okay
maybe you need someone in charge of
sorting the incoming souls into the
different levels of hell but after that
isn't it just an eternity of torture how
much lording does it take to put william
shatner's the transformed man on repeat
for example if time is slowed down then
from the perspective of these partiers
lucifer and a menin deal should be
moving extremely fast so why aren't they
reacting to the sudden speedsters
they're supposed to also be invisible
what's the point of slowing time down
show off what exactly do you think
happens when the devil leaves hell i'm
guessing countless parties and everyone
stays up past their bedtime does
anything else happen when the parents
leave town i'll be honest all my life
knowledge comes via movies from the
1980s you know
you will not be merciful for much longer
you know some people's version of hell
is experiencing round after round of the
pronoun game just saying if all these
women outside were snapping pictures and
acting like crazed hyenas around delilah
then how is she able to sit at this bar
without being bothered by at least a few
fans
i'm definitely curious about the
identity of the shooter and who hired
him but i'm more curious about where all
the cars that were clearly in front of
the shooter's vehicle in the previous
shot went hey man
i'm pretty sure a i mean i'm only the
murderer defense doesn't go over great
with a jury but you do you hired
assassin i wouldn't pick at it too hard
not after palmetto street oh yeah
remember that thing at palmetto street
with the guy and that other thing he did
that terrible thing to that other guy
yeah that was wild and super relevant
also i am so relieved to see another cop
story that has an underdog detective
trying to prove their worth after a
vague case that went wrong who says
fresh ideas are better
me i do lucifer morningstar lucifer is
latin for morningstar this means the
same god that created the world in its
surrounding universe in all of its
complex splendor and unlimited
magnificence also called his son lucifer
lucifer ran out of imagination after
unicorns did we so you had a
conversation with a dead guy why would
decker assume that the man died before
lucifer was able to speak to him unless
of course she wanted to give him a
chance to be vague about his abilities
also one thing i find very curious is
that no one ever brings up the driver of
the vehicle eddie was in the back of the
vehicle maybe the driver died but that's
never brought up either it just seems
like looking into the driver might give
them clues as well but what do i know
i'm not a detective but i'm not really
sure these people are either you humans
you love your money don't you that's
humanist wait no that's something else
entirely how does she end up dying in a
hailstorm of bullets and you get away
without a scratch i think that's
interesting don't you the benefits of
immortality if lucifer has no issues
talking about his immortality and
referring to people as you humans why is
he bothering to go through with the
pretense of owning a bar and looking
human himself excuse me yeah i have a
problem wedding crashers yeah good luck
with that padre oh while you're at it
say hey from me it's been a while so
does the preacher actually know he's
lucifer because that brings up questions
and can be a really interesting avenue
for this episode to explore but instead
let's just have this unfunny and generic
name calling session with lucifer and
jimmy then we can continue with this
uninteresting and generic police
procedural good afternoon sir english
butler cliche i have no contacts for him
right this way sir two vial would be
wise to invest in some better security
measures if this is all it takes to get
through the front [ __ ] door lucifer
morning stuff let's get hip nights
forgive me if i don't trust your
judgment on what constitutes a good
hip-hop name mr tuvile what you don't
like hip-hop no i must certainly do not
disliking hip-hop
two-vial would be too excellent at tv
since ah yes nothing says hip-hop and
guns quite like this green animal-shaped
chair stool thing that looks like it
came from ikea i had her once cause i
found out she was cheating on me oh well
in that case i was forgiven i'm glad we
sorted out this dreadful
misunderstanding i ran the dead guy's
cell phone tuval was the last person he
called oh man and what i find highly
interesting is how you made the
connection on your own is it honestly
surprising that lucifer would be aware
of delilah's ex-boyfriends and make that
his first point of call especially
considering she's a celebrity the real
question detective is why did you need
to run the dead guy's phone to make this
very basic deductive leap hot tub high
school that's where i know you're from
let's just stick to my question shall we
the one with the famous nude sink i
sincerely hope the nude scene in
question from hot tub high school
focuses on the teachers and not the
students or else i expect lucifer to
personally escort all of these people to
a very special level of hell she was
like the new phoebe cates thanks i
appreciate that that was quite a nude
scene i have far too many bullets in
this thing for you to still be talking
this show has plenty of problems but tom
ellis and lauren german's repartee isn't
one of them they have magnificent
chemistry right off the bat and i could
be easily led down a path of watching
them solve mysteries every week i've
just threatened his life he's not our
guy i would have said trust me you did
what yes lucifer just admitted to
threatening another person's life and
that should be dealt with but she's
going to completely ignore two vials
drug purchasing admission and whether or
not anyone here has a license for the
copious amounts of guns currently being
collected by the most ineffectual butler
since winston in the tomb raider 2 video
game i got it i got it the name the
whole lucifer thing you're really just
now getting this connection decker you
are a detective right i know something
you don't know
really what's that won't say unless you
take me with you on this this works my
mother's police officer she could arrest
you
i think i might know your mother well
isn't that a devil of a convenience you
could say the devil is in the details
okay i'll stop but i was having such a
devil of a good time please don't
unsubscribe did you know there's a
special section of hell reserved for
bullies so
have fun bullies are the worst but
there's a chance that this kid isn't all
evil maybe we shouldn't be skipping juvi
and jumping straight to eternity of
damnation quite yet perhaps you should
refrain from arguing in front of the
child it's unbecoming i don't know
whether to laugh or to shoot you
threatening to shoot a man you just met
in front of your [ __ ] child
especially after said man has just made
a damn valid point
she likes you
of course she does what's not to like
vanity so never understood the human
desire to procreate oh i don't know
shall we start with avoiding extinction
are you at all aware of how dickish you
sound a question my friends and family
ask when i explain what i do for a
living somehow makes its way into this
episode i guess i can understand why
decker brought lucifer along to this
point but i don't understand why she
would bring him in with her when she
questions the psychiatrist if anything
comes of this lucifer's involvement
could hamper the investigation and
possibly even derail it there have to be
some legalities involved if she's
choosing to go down this path actually
it's interesting because
you don't look at me that way episode
has time for this delilah was having a
quindestin affair with a wealthy married
man so if you just tell us his name we
will be on our way i'm sorry i can't do
that now doctor patient confidentiality
extends beyond the grave but it can be
preached with a court order if a judge
deems it in the public interest this is
something that decker would know so why
would she waste your time coming here
without said court order other than to
provide lucifer with the opportunity to
show off his satanically sanguine
seductive solution of course i do yoga
hot
yoga rachel hayes is a treasure and we
do not deserve her really tried to keep
that one in title of my sex tape hey hey
sir so this guy just stopped after the
first hey sir why is everyone so bad at
their jobs in this show i'm the
president of the united states of
america no need to be embarrassed hell
if arnold can do it right evidently this
show takes place in an alternate reality
where arnold schwarzenegger was elected
president knowing this episode aired in
2016 that actually sounds less
ridiculous than what we ended up with my
bodyguard
what a cliche actually my bodyguard is a
pretty original movie and a very
charming and entertaining one as well
now this show on the other hand
post-mortem pre-shadowing maybe delilah
gave him one too like kind of a go-to
gift i well that would imply she was
actually sleeping with that maggot or
that she paid for drugs with a watch or
they had become friends who gave each
other christmas gifts or he was never at
any of their meetups on time and she got
sick of always waiting on him people do
give gifts without sex being involved
god what am i doing here wrong deity but
yes that is the eternal question god
these god quips from lucifer every time
the word god is mentioned are god-awful
no one wants to work with me
well i'm available available but not a
cop shows like this always find a way to
shoehorn the main character into some
sort of consultant role but how is
decker going to justify putting the
owner of a nightclub in self-proclaimed
lord of the underworld on the precinct's
payroll the soundtrack album for the
movie time will tell has reached number
15 on the billboard charts
in the name of satan's sainted slippers
i swear this perfectly timed news report
of convenience has contributed more to
the resolution of this murder inquiry
than both of these two chuckles combined
also what the [ __ ] is up with this bar
chart the scale here shows the positions
from 70 to 1 in increments of 10. so why
isn't the 51 bar somewhere between 60
and 50 in the 66 bar between 60 and 70.
why would anyone even need to do this
manually excel will line that up for you
in a second damn it if there's one thing
that i will not abide by it's a sloppy
attitude towards accurate data
presentation the watch delilah gave you
now that's just sick great bit of
deductive reasoning team but if lucifer
had thought to use the jedi mind tricks
back at jimmy's wedding he could have
gotten jimmy to admit this and saved us
a whole lot of time and this show a ton
of sins also jimmy really thought that
the best form of payment for an
assassination was the watch that was
gifted to him by the very person he is
paying to have assassinated yes i know
jimmy probably didn't expect the shooter
to be wiped out by a bus and be
immediately found at the murder scene
with said incriminating timepiece but
it's still a needlessly risky move why
not pawn the watch and pay him in cash
i'm sure he's going the pain's coming no
no it's not actually and you know why
because i'm here so are all the current
and future denizens of hell currently
living it up and having a great time
just because lucifer is left does that
mean he was personally seeing to all the
torturing good lord man learn to
delegate this barrage of bullets barely
seems to have an impact on lucifer so
why did the ones from the initial
shooting appear to knock him unconscious
how long have i been out
three years
what
amnesia jokes
lucifer there is a balance here that we
must maintain then in the name of your
father do something about it all you've
done so far is politely ask if he
wouldn't terribly mind returning to hell
at his earliest convenience rather than
flexing his wings of doom does amenity
will have any ability to stop our
beguiling british beelzebub at all i'm
worried the humans are rubbing off on
you if the therapist from earlier is
anything to go by i'm fairly confident
the rubbing is a two-way deal we can
have as much naked cuddle time as you
desire but you're gonna have to listen
to me too i'm always happy to see
therapy promoted in popular culture but
something tells me this isn't a
particularly realistic or healthy
representation of the profession and
honestly that deserves a hell of a lot
of sins
you're going to burn in a very special
level of hell
you want to shag me
you want to shag me no no no you want to
shag me no no no no you want to shag me
all right hold on a tick that's not
right i'm going to warn you against
disrespecting our father lucifer let me
give you a little inside information
about god
i assumed as you're taking on the
underworld this symbol
is a persona to protect those you care
about from reprisals are you thinking
about rachel actually uh i think that
myself
right i can get out of this you know
magic no i can't read people's minds not
jedi i find your lack of faith
disturbing